[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to the Google-Plex.
I'm Laurence Moroney.
And I'm here today
with Scott Jensen.
SCOTT JENSEN: Hey.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And Scott
is the maestro of all things
Internet of Things, and
in particular something
called the physical web.
So we're going to get together.
We're going to talk
about the physical web.
And I know I'm going to learn
a lot, and I hope you do, too.
So Scott, physical web, that's
what we're here to talk about.
Tell us all about it.
SCOTT JENSEN: OK.
Well, when people talk about
the Internet of Things,
there's so much to it.
There's networking protocols
and data standards and so forth.
But we're trying to solve the
front-end piece of it, which
is to say you want to walk up to
a device and be able to use it.
So there's things like the
Nest, or Bluetooth door locks,
or Zipcars.
All these devices
today have an app
that you have to install to use.
And that's fine, if you only
have two or three devices
in your life.
But if we believe in
Moore's Law at all,
there's going to be thousands if
not billions of these devices,
a lot of them in public places.
And apps just don't scale.
If you're in the
middle of a mall,
you're not going to download an
app to talk to a movie poster.
It's just not going to work.
So we're trying to get rid
of all of that friction,
so that you can just
with a couple of taps
interact with the device that
you're standing in front of.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
Now, how does this get rid
of that kind of friction?
How is it engineered to do that?
SCOTT JENSEN: Well,
the way we're doing it
right now is we're using
Bluetooth low energy.
It's a new version of Bluetooth.
It's extremely low power.
It broadcasts a URL in
the advertising packet.
And it does it once a
second, over and over again.
But it's so low power, it's
actually measured in microamps.
It's not even milliamps.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Interesting.
SCOTT JENSEN: So a
little tiny coin cell
can last for over a year.
And of course, if you
attach it to something
that's plugged into the
wall, it's infinite.
But the intention is that
you just broadcast the URL
over and over again.
And then your phone, or
your tablet, or eventually
your headset could
then just scan
for all the URLs in
the area around you
and then rank them
and let you pick.
But it won't be shout-y.
It won't be in your face.
You will only be able to
do it if you ask for it.
You open your phone, pull
down the notification manager,
see what's nearby, and
then when you tap on it,
it just takes you there.
So it's meant to be
you're under control,
and you do it when you're ready.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
Now, is there some
way of it being
able to filter out
the kind of things
that I'd be interested
in and the kind of things
that I'm not?
SCOTT JENSEN: Well, initially
what we're trying to do
is to get you to see the
thing that you're in front of.
But because we go
through a proxy server,
we can kind of do
some safe searching
and so make sure we get rid
o spam and things like that.
But we also are
thinking about having
it have some sense of history,
so that the things that you use
more often will rise to the
top, or things in your house,
you could actually star
so that it would actually
make sure it pops to the top.
So we're experimenting with
a lot of different ways
to make sure that if you
do see a lot of things,
the things that are
important to you show up.
LAURENCE MORONEY: You
mentioned you're experimenting
a lot of different ways.
What kind of stuff
have you built?
Anything fun or interesting?
SCOTT JENSEN: Well,
what I've done right now
is last year I
went and on eBay I
bought a vending
machine for $250.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
A vending machine?
SCOTT JENSEN: And I bought
it myself, took it all apart,
and put in a Raspberry
Pi, just to simulate
what we could start to do.
And the idea is you walk
up to the vending machine.
It's broadcasting the URL.
You then go to the website.
And then, you can use any
kind of web payment means
that you want to.
But then when I actually click
on the thing that I want,
it just sends a
WebSocket message
from the web server
to the Raspberry
Pi, which then spins
a little relay,
and it just drops the candy.
And the whole thing takes
less than 100 milliseconds.
It's kind of cool.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That is pretty cool.
SCOTT JENSEN: And right
now, I'm just simulating
just the actual purchase.
But we can do so
much more than that.
Because when I actually
talked to Coke about this,
they got really excited.
And they were like,
wait a second,
we could change the
whole experience
and be like,
"Welcome back, Scott.
Do you want Diet Dr Pepper?"
So it can remember.
Or "I see that you've bought 10.
Do you want the
eleventh one free?"
So it's not just
simply about payment.
It's actually about changing
the entire experience.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So Scott, what
is it that brought you to this?
And what made you think of
working with the physical web?
SCOTT JENSEN: I'm actually
a UX designer by training.
And I've worked an
awful lot with companies
that are trying to both use
websites and applications.
And it became really
clear that there
was this effort involved
with using applications
for thin, lightweight things.
And it became really
clear that there's
a UX issue involved about
being able to the interaction
as quickly as possible.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
At heart, it's really a user
experience of technology.
Right?
SCOTT JENSEN: Well, precisely.
Because the web is this
really lovely white box
we call the DOM.
And all these years,
but on top of it
we have this little URL
bar that hasn't really
changed in 25 years.
It's a DOS prompt
on top of the web.
We have to go dub,
dub, dub dot cnn dot.
It's like, we haven't
changed that in so long.
Why can't the mobile phone
browser use the same sensors
that every other app has?
All the physical
web is trying to do
is let the browser
use the sensors that
are on the phone in itself.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
So that gives the
scenario that you
were talking about earlier on.
If I'm in a shopping mall
and I see a movie poster,
that movie poster could
be broadcasting the URL.
My phone sees that URL.
And then that URL could
give me the trailer
or give me a link to buy tickets
or something along those lines.
SCOTT JENSEN: Oh, precisely.
LAURENCE MORONEY: A much
better user experience
than me looking at
the poster and then
trying to pull out my
phone and figure out
how I can learn more about it.
SCOTT JENSEN: Well,
and some people
have said, well, wait a second.
We have QR codes.
Why don't those work?
And QR codes tried
to solve a problem.
But as we all know, it
wasn't very effective,
because no one's going
to take out their phone
and focus on one little thing.
And we can do 50 URLs from 50
meters away simultaneously.
It's a totally different idea.
And by making it
UX-driven, we're
trying to make it
effortless and fast.
And the technology, we initially
tried using Bluetooth regular
and realized it
wasn't appropriate.
We even tried using Wi-Fi.
It wasn't appropriate.
So we've been trying to do this,
until Bluetooth as low energy
came out, that actually
made it kind of work.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
Cool.
So you spoke about
the URL almost
being like the DOS
prompt of the internet,
and this thing's
broadcasting URLs.
So does that mean it's just
a browser-only technology?
SCOTT JENSEN: Well,
the advantage of URLs
is they're so flexible.
So initially having the
URL take you to a web pages
is the quickest,
lightest way to go.
But it can also deeply get
into a native application.
So when I was talking
to one company that
wanted to use this, they
already have an app.
But they loved the idea that
the web browser would now
allow someone to walk
up to their device
and use it right away.
And then, once they
kind of get hooked,
they can install
the app and then get
a different kind of experience.
So URLs cross both boundaries,
which is really quite nice.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
Yeah.
Because, of course, it can
describe a web location,
and it could describe
context in an application.
SCOTT JENSEN: Well,
and also URLs are just
really flexible in cool ways.
Like, I have a
temperature sensor,
and the URL can actually add
and ampersand t equal 72.
So the URL can
dynamically change.
Or if you want to
have a URL with an 8-
or 12-digit rotating ID that
can't be copied or spoofed
for extra-secure applications.
So the URL provides
a lot of levers
that we can pull and grow
over time as this changes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
So that makes it
really flexible.
SCOTT JENSEN: Yes.
Exactly.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Awesome.
Cool.
So now this kind
of thing has got
to be open for everybody to
be able to build with, right?
Or it doesn't really work.
What's the developer
story behind this?
SCOTT JENSEN: Well, because
I'm on the Chrome team,
and we're filled with a
bunch of goody two shoes
on the Chrome team,
we just really
want everything to be open.
And it's a really cool team
to be involved with that.
This is completely open source.
So our prototype app is from
open source, the proxy server,
the beacon firmware,
all of it is wide open
and there to be used.
And we very much want this to
be effectively an extension
to the browser.
So we want this to be on
every platform, every browser,
everywhere.
And so this is not
a Google product.
And I mean, we're most likely
going to be implementing it
through Chrome eventually.
But the goal though is to have
this be available to everyone.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
So where would the source be?
Or where can developers
get started with looking
at the [INAUDIBLE] now?
SCOTT JENSEN: So
we have a GitHub.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
There is a GitHub.
Perfect.
SCOTT JENSEN: And
we have two GitHubs.
We have one for the
overall project called
the physical web, which
has the application
and the proxy server.
And then, we have a separate
one for just the beacon,
which is called the URI
beacon, U-R-I beacon.
And the intentions is--
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That kind of URI.
SCOTT JENSEN: Yes.
And we're trying to create
two different effectively
ecosystems.
We're trying to create
an ecosystem of devices
that are broadcasting.
And they're just always
broadcasting the URLs.
And that needs to
be massively open.
And that's where we're using the
Bluetooth low energy standard
and the advertising packet.
And it's just broadcasting those
things over and over again.
And then, we have
a whole other cloud
of devices that are
listening and ranking.
And we hope to be a
lot of experimentation.
There is already somebody
who has implemented
for Google Glass, for example.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
SCOTT JENSEN: And someone
is trying for Firefox OS
and things like that.
So we've got lots
of different groups
that are playing around it.
And they may try different ways
of ranking and organizing them.
And that's to be expected,
and we hope that happens.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now, you
mentioned on the hardware side
there's Bluetooth low energy.
Is that the only standard?
Or are there others?
SCOTT JENSEN: Well,
Bluetooth low energy
is kind of the new black.
Everyone's excited by it.
Everyone's doing that.
But we also have
support for MDNS,
which is a Wi-Fi based
technology, which
is really handy, so that
if you're in your house,
you don't necessarily want
your neighbor know you just
bought a 120-inch television.
We actually have
ways around that.
We talked about
ways, for example,
that your TV could be
broadcasting an obfuscated URL.
And then, when you walk up
to it and you first buy it,
you could push a button
and then it gives you a URL
that you can connect to.
And then, it gives you a
cookie, because it's the web.
And then, only you
can connect to it.
So that's one way around it.
But MDNS goes through
your Wi-Fi network, which
really is much more secure.
And we've even had a German
research company, FontHopper,
just go to our GitHub.
And they added UPnP
support as well.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
SCOTT JENSEN: So we're
trying to effectively
be the technology of
broadcasting URLs.
And we want to have multiple
ways in which it can happen.
What I have noticed
is that people
love open-source projects as
long as you do all the work.
So I think what
people are waiting
for is for Google to get behind
this and to really push it.
And then, once we get
behind it and start going,
then they're going to
say, it's open, right.
And I think that's
the important part
about this is that we have
to kind of make the market.
And we have to kind
of get people excited.
But frankly, that's
so not a problem.
We already have people
chomping at the bit
that we just have to kind
of get the ecosystem going.
And so we're really hoping that
Microsoft, Firefox OS, even
Apple, will kind of
say, hey, we can kind of
get on board with this, too.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
Now, is this something that has
to be built into the browser
and that's why you
mentioned those companies?
SCOTT JENSEN: Well,
building it into the browser
we feel is the
best way to do it,
because that way it offers,
again, more competition.
So if Chrome did it and Firefox
did it and you had them both,
you can pick and choose
which way you want to do it.
So we think this is more
appropriate at the browser
level than it is at the
operating system level.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Makes perfect sense.
Cool.
So everybody, that's it.
We're finished in our
chat with Scott for today
on the physical web.
Thanks, Scott, for being here.
SCOTT JENSEN:
You're very welcome.
Glad to be here.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
I've learned so much
in just these few minutes.
And I hope you have, too.
And be sure to go check out
the GitHub on GitHub itself.
You can just search
for physical web,
and you'll find everything
that Scott has spoken about.
And I believe, Scott,
you're constantly on there,
you know, fixing code,
answering questions,
and all that kind of thing.
SCOTT JENSEN: That's how
we want to engage people
That's the best way to do it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: All right.
So thanks, everybody.
And again, thanks, Scott.
[MUSIC PLAYING]